what up guys welcome to the just Hurley
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down where I really bring on
different guests to talk about we'll
either do like one-on-one interviews or
just the news of the week so this week
I'm bringing on I would say you're a
channel regular at this point based I
like it Rachel Rachel Wilson who is one
I would say she is so smart like
literally so smart for a woman sorry
about I don't know if I can make this
joke with and they won't get back no but
seriously seriously Rachel um wrote a
book on feminism called The Cult
feminism and I literally don't know
anybody that can like cite facts off the
top of her head just like so quickly
tell you the exact source and place
um so welcome to the show Rachel yeah
thanks for having me back again it's
always fun to be here this week I was
inspired I was inspired we were just
talking about this I was inspired on
Twitter so I always talk I want to make
really clear to the audience my thoughts
on marriage and fam because everybody
all always you know Rachel you're the
only one that understands what I'm
saying so I think that marriage and
family is an amazing thing I think it's
phenomenal however with the divorce laws
today I do not see women acting better
for men that sign up so I would tell men
to be very hesitant protect yourself in
every way and even some men it's
probably in their best interest to walk
away in my opinion every guy's got a
pick for himself I can't really tell you
you gotta weigh the pros and the cons
there's ways to mitigate it right
religion I think Orthodox you know that
it seems like you guys have better
outcomes I'm Orthodox Catholic same
thing it seems like there's ways to
mitigate risk but there's no sure thing
and for whatever reason with female
nature when we get power we just tend to
be bad with it don't know why don't know
why we're like this but it seems to be
the way and whenever I point this stuff
out I get I get accused of being a
Doomer attack a red pill attack on
marriage or basically just hating women
as my usual I just wake up and think how
can I hate women today me too same
just wake up every day wondering how I
can make life hard for women yeah yeah
and be mean to them and my point is I
don't think you could push men into
marriage I think we have to figure out
how to get the divorce laws to change I
think this can be done through suing I
know there's a lawsuit going on in
England against kafkas you know I think
all the men have to get together I don't
know the exact way to do it I'm not a
policy maker you know I do I don't know
the exact solution but in my opinion
maybe it's suing some of these
organizations maybe it's walking away
from Marriage until it switches I I
don't know but my thing is I understand
men's hesitation to not want to get
married I even understand I'm not I
don't recommend it but I even understand
a vasectomy because it is so freaking
risky for men today there's no way for
men to interact with a woman without
having a legal consequence yes and you
know what I realized is I really started
I don't want to say hating women I don't
hate women but having a frustration with
women because I thought to myself why is
it whenever we do this stuff you know we
just get evil with power okay and I
thought about it and I'm like well we're
just like kids it's like giving kids
free Reigns
and then getting no who's who's
responsible for bad kids the parent and
I realize that everything goes back to
simping
which is what I wanted to talk about
today so I brought on our good friend
Rachel to talk about the history of
simping yes and oh boy like it goes all
the way back to the beginning of time so
my book on feminism starts like with
ancient Origins and feminism starting in
the ancient world and simping simping is
what started that right so we're gonna I
have three um like of History's worst
Sims for you guys today and they are
Tales of caution right please don't say
jump because you're going to see what
happens to some of the most powerful and
greatest men who've ever lived who made
the mistake of simping so like nobody's
immune you can be like the top Alpha Dog
and if you simp it's gonna be over for
you we hates them we hate them there
wouldn't there wouldn't be all these
problems and all these thirst traps and
all these 304s and only fans and
everything if it wasn't for simps so so
who was like the first recorded simp do
you have do you know well the first
recorded simp would probably be Adam
right
well because Eve you know was tempted
and ate the fruit and Adam rather than
obeying God who like imagine you're
walking every day in the garden with God
you're with God okay it's not even like
a far-off concept for you it's like you
know God and you're still gonna you
don't want the woman to get in trouble
alone so you're gonna go into it with
her and then when God confronts them and
he says what have you done to Adam he
said it wasn't me it's this woman that
you gave me
so he would probably be the first one
but right after him we have a great
story about simping a legendary Tale in
the Bible in the Book of Judges about
Samson and Delilah so Samson was the
strongest man kind of known to the world
at the time he was alive he had
incredible like strong man Feats he
could do he could take out whole armies
like by himself and he goes to a town
and the people who are there in charge
want to want to get rid of him because
he's been like picking the crap out of
all their armies and stuff so they're
like we gotta get rid of this guy so
what did they do how do they get to the
store I mean it's always the women they
send a woman so they go to this woman
Delilah and they say look we want to do
like the classic Espionage move of send
this hot chicken you you get in his
pants and you learn his secrets so we
can take him out she's like okay so she
goes to him and asks him you know what's
the secret to your strength and and how
can you be defeated now at first he's
guarded at first he's like I'm I'm not
gonna tell her that the real thing so he
tells her like a phony thing he says oh
if you have like this certain type of
rope and you tie it around me then you
can defeat me so she goes back and tells
his enemies they try to capture him but
she he told her the wrong thing so it
doesn't work so a few days later she
tries again asks him again and he gives
her a different bony thing right oh if
you if you do it this way then you can
defeat me so she runs back tells his
enemies they try that to capture him
that way that doesn't work either so the
third time here's where everything goes
wrong she comes to him and she says this
is actually the the verse from the
Orthodox Study Bible she says how can
you say I love you when your heart is
not with me you deceived me a third time
and you still have not told me where
your great strength lies so she
basically went you don't even love me
that's what we do that's what we do so
that's what she does and listen to this
this is incredible I was reading this
last night going I don't know why I
didn't see this before so she said he
says and it came to pass after she
pestered him continually with her words
and pressured him sorely that his Spirit
failed him almost to death so this [__]
nagged him to death okay
this is how she got to him was literally
by nagging him to the point that he was
like that I'm gonna I'm about to you
know I know they say child birth is our
greatest superpower but I actually think
it's nagging because the amount that a
woman
can influence meth like we basically
nagged men into giving us a voting
rights abortions we basically nagged men
into ruining Society yeah like if you
give us enough time and we just never
shut up eventually the men are like I'm
gonna die if I don't just get rid of
this sometimes sometimes they gotta tell
a [__] to shut up do you know what I
mean like my husband is the nicest man
to me and sometimes he'll be doing
something and I'll I'll come up and
start prattling at him with woman
pruddle of Billy Connie today and I'm
just telling him something and he'll be
like uh-huh but if I go too long and
he's busy he'll turn and look at me and
he'll be like sweetheart I love you
please shut up
and I'm like oh sorry okay and I but I
don't get mad I'm just like oh all right
no problem I'll pester you later when
you're not busy but this is how she
finally I just read the verse and I was
like wow I can't believe even the Bible
says she pestered him continually with
her words and pressured him sorely that
his Spirit failed him almost to death I
just think that's like we're talking 6
000 years ago okay that this happened
and this is the way it's described even
then so this is clearly like an innate
human thing right this has been
something that's gone on from the
beginning of time so finally he gives in
and it says then he told her everything
in his heart and said to her no razor
has ever come upon my head for I've been
a holy one from God from my mother's
womb if I am shaven then my strength
will leave me and I shall become weak
like all the other men so she this she
says Delilah discerned he told her all
of his heart and she sent and called for
the leaders of the Philistines saying
come up once more for he told me all his
heart so basically he finally like let
his guard down and really like let her
in and told him ever told her everything
that was in his heart which I thought
that was like a really interesting
phrasing because I think that's what
happens to a lot of guys right they open
up and like let a woman into their heart
and then she'll use whatever is in there
yeah oh I see her weakness now and now
I'm gonna play on that weakness to get
the advantage in the relationship and
then they'll like that's what they do I
just heard a guy breaking this down how
in like Divorce Court that's what the
chicks will do they're like and the
lawyers they'll give them like all of
the guys Secrets basically that he
wouldn't want people to know yeah yeah
so that's like this is what's happening
like you know in the beginning of
recorded history so it says Delilah
lulled Samson to sleep on her knees and
called for a man and had him shave off
the Seven Locks of his head thus she
could finally subdue and control him for
his strength departed from him and then
it says that when this happened when he
let the woman have a secret he kind of
betrayed God because God had given him
this superhuman strength to be like a
defender of Israel and so when he
betrayed that trust by telling her how
to defeat him it says the Lord had
departed from him so this to me I'm
thinking this is kind of a way of saying
if you abandon your role as a man which
is to be the head of the woman if you
let her up on that pedestal with you on
equal part the Lord may leave you like
he may be saying nope that's not the
order I established this is what I want
from you I need the men that I you know
bless with certain strengths to be doing
what they do for me not for some woman
right not because you're lusting after a
woman you you need to be following me so
same thing that happened with Adam Adam
kind of betrayed God to simp for a woman
Samson does the same thing so the Lord
leaves him and he's they take out his
eyes they capture him and finally like
he's they're basically making him into a
circus freak so they make him do like
strong man tricks and they watch and
they all party and they're all laughing
at him and humiliating him and he just
gets really wrecked right and it says um
he's kind of at the end of it where he's
like okay they're gonna kill me I'm
probably gonna die so he says Lord my
Lord remember me now oh God strengthened
me just this one so with one blow I may
take Vengeance on the Philistines for my
two eyes so the Lord gives him just
enough strength to knock down the
pillars of the house he's in that it's
like a big mansion where all these
people are living and kills everybody
inside it also kills him but it kills
everybody inside so God does at least
Grant him just enough strength to have
some Vengeance on his enemies but man I
was just like this is such a such a
disheartening story of Simply all the
way from the Old Testament you know what
I thought about how unbiblical it is for
women to not obey their like why do we
expect men to obey God in all things if
we can't obey our husband in all things
that's exactly what it is that's what
we're supposed to do and by obeying her
husband and all things we are obeying
God and the men are supposed to obey God
they're not supposed to obey us
regardless of the nagging right his
mistake was when he realized she was
treacherous and that she was after him
and nagging him and trying to get him to
Bear secrets that were none of her
business what would she need to know
that for his wisdom should have told him
get rid of this broad right yeah get
this chick away from you but he didn't
do that because he was following like
his lust and and he was simping so right
it was the death of him well and that's
why like when guys will they always come
at me because they're like Pearl like
you're not married but I'm like okay you
realize like when you say things like
happy wife happy life it's cheaper to
keep her like that says something about
the way we do man marriage today yeah
and you're basically admitting that it
sucks yeah like that that I'm a bit Yeah
I consider simps women yeah I would look
I would totally agree with that that's
kind of how I see them too it's like
because it's like how are you more
feminine than me like I'm willing I'm
submissive to my husband but you're over
here like telling me I'm wrong for doing
that and that I should Rachel why don't
you um let him do more chores yeah
they're like how why do you hate
yourself why won't you make your husband
wash the dishes and I'm like oh my gosh
right there is the funniest thing when
he was talking about your royalties oh
yeah
now my husband has this running thing
that he does all the time where he'll
promote my book tell everybody to buy my
book he's like I'm gonna snatch all her
royalties she's not getting a sense I'm
taking all of it and I'm gonna buy
myself a truck I'm gonna become one of
those truck guys right I'm gonna get
super pimped out truck that costs more
money than my house and I'm just gonna
treat it like my baby
it's not like his way of giving them the
finger which is hilarious to me well no
and that's like the that's the thing is
it's like it's so rare to see I was
thinking about you the other day I was
like it's so rare to see women that
actually like support their husbands
it's so sad
it's so sad you're like baby here the
royalties are yours I don't care
well it's not my money okay this is
another thing that God I should probably
tweet this later because everyone will
get mad it's not my money okay it's he's
the head of the household he's been the
breadwinner forever since we've been
together and it's not so the money isn't
mine it's I give it to him and he wisely
uses it to support the family that's
what he's supposed to do now I'm lucky
my husband is super nice to me and
probably spoils me more than he should
but he only does that to the extent that
like I kind of earn it if that makes
sense so like if there's no reason for
him to say no to me about like something
I want to buy he just won't but also I
don't buy a lot of stuff I'm just not I
don't know if it's because I was raised
like Dutch or something and we're just
really tight Penny Pinchers but I'm just
not an extravagant person I don't have
expensive purses I don't buy designer
clothes there's like none of that stuff
going on well and like that's the
they'll always come at me because
they'll be like oh like so you're saying
like you shouldn't get married or you're
saying like oh she married because you
were a single mom for right and so but
it's like but it's like the Sim pick is
only giving it to a woman that doesn't
deserve it and making her do nothing
like that is the point and 90 of
relationships they they don't make the
girl do anything and women hate men that
just give it to us they don't know why
we're like that the men are logical sir
like that doesn't make sense I would
love a girl that just gave me sex like
yeah yeah we're like when you just give
it to we just don't whatever it is well
we're gonna we're gonna find out in the
next two simp stories why the women hate
it I think oh okay go ahead so this is a
real this is huge there's so many I
could have picked from but this one I
feel like it's maybe like the worst of
all the Sims stories and I have to read
like a little bit of stuff from it but
only for like good purposes so Emperor
Napoleon Bonaparte France you guys the
legendary military strategist the
emperor of France who conquered all
these lands that you know France hadn't
like seen military carry victories like
this ever this guy was amazing but he
was one of the biggest simps and once
again he gets completely undone by
simply so Napoleon grows up on the
island of Corsica outside France he goes
to like a French military school and
they realize wow this guy's like really
talented at military strategy so he
joins the French army he begins to have
all of this success in like taking
territory for France and launching
military campaigns and he's really
getting beloved and Popular by France
but you know he's gonna have to if he's
gonna become emperor he's got to marry
somebody and produce an error an heir
and he meets this woman named Josephine
and she was six years older than him and
she had two kids from her first marriage
her first husband got guillotined in the
French Revolution so he got killed and
she kind of escaped getting Guillotine
herself by sleeping with some of the
aristocrats that that beheaded her
husband as they do that do you know what
that's that's such a it's such a woman
thing thing to like our husbands get
killed and we just F whoever killed him
yes that's exactly what she did so at
the time he was being killed um she was
under like kind of a house arrest they
arrested her as well right so she was
under this like house arrest for
Aristocrats that wasn't like too
terrible and some of the very like
powerful French politicians she had
affairs with so even after she had
affairs before he was arrested too like
oh so she had been a loose lady since
the beginning yeah so even while she was
married to her first husband yes he
cheated but she also cheated she
actually I'm sorry you know what she did
she got so you couldn't get a divorce
then but she went to like a magistrate
and got a legal separation from her
husband so that she could have a
separate house what time period was this
so this is uh late 1700s so I have a
question do you because I have this
Theory and I'm just one because when I
think of like women nature and when I
when I say women nature I don't say all
women will succumb to our nature right
some women understand we're like this
and don't do it or raised better
whatever but it's whenever women are
surrounded by high value Men We tend to
Monkey branch and just cheat yeah so
yeah I was wondering if there was more
promiscuity among Elite women and
Noble's wives rather than the average
population oh because yeah okay because
that's what I was thinking because I'm
like I mean like what the peasant's
wife's gonna maybe cheat with another
peasant like but like she's busy on the
farm doing stuff yeah there's like
nothing to gain right and I'm thinking
like but these women like I was thinking
Elite Men actually probably have a
harder time back then getting their
wives to stay faithful than average man
I would argue today because of Instagram
now the average men get cheated on more
right because they have access to like
the noble like imagine if the peasants
wives had access to the Nobles and Kings
it would be done yeah totally and they
but they didn't so I think you're that
was a very good observation I think it
was true through and I think that's
where this idea when people say like but
men always are the ones that are
cheaters think about the this king or
this noble guy who cheated and it's like
yeah the the elite men cheated but the
elite women did too so like she's the
one who went to like you know one of
their judges or whatever and since you
can't get a divorce because the reason
you couldn't in large part was because
if you're very wealthy and you have
these huge Estates and all this wealth
like you can't just leave and take the
guy's kids because then he has nobody to
pass it down to so even if he's kind of
done with you you can't do the legal
divorce because it ruins everything for
your kids so they didn't do that but she
did get them to allow her to have her
own house and take a bunch of his money
so that she could go off and have like
however many lovers she wanted to have
and is that is that in that time period
is that like a new phenomenon or no
um I would have to go back and see like
when that started but this this period
in particular the revolutionary period
where you've got the French Revolution
and then the American Revolution
everybody was getting very liberal this
is the beginning of this do whatever you
want as long as it doesn't hurt anybody
kind of mentality where they start to
abandon a lot of the tradition and kind
of do what they want it was very liberal
especially like the French Aristocrats
they were some of the worst at this sort
of thing so yeah she goes off and she's
cheating and then her husband dies he
has a year between when her husband dies
and she meets Napoleon where she has
like several affairs with multiple
French politics she was just getting
passed around to the French air stalker
see basically and so he meets her at a
party in 1763. he's 26 and she's 32 and
she's known for being like a big spender
she she has a lot of wealth but she's
like got really expensive taste she's
like a really high maintenance woman of
the time and he just Falls madly in love
with her and they're sleeping together
like they sleep together right away
there was no like waiting for marriage
or anything because again these are
French Aristocrats in the revolutionary
period everyone's partying and so they
sleep together and he starts writing her
letter you guys and the letters are just
embarrassing now remember this is a man
who like is a brilliant military
strategist and goes to war and kicks
everyone's ass but listen to how listen
to how he talks to her in these letters
and you can find these anywhere online
if you want to read them yourself
because they're they're kind of funny
but they're exactly like what we see
today so he does marry her against the
wishes of his whole family they were
like what the hell are you doing
you're marrying a woman in her 30s who
already has like grown children and
you're 20 like you're 26 what are you
thinking but he's just he got whipped
okay yeah so he marries her and on the
marriage certificate she lies about her
age to make herself four years younger
and closer to him in age so that's
hilarious and right after they get
married he has to go off and do a war
campaign and he wants her to come with
so that they can have a honeymoon but
she doesn't want to she doesn't go with
him she stays back because she's already
got a different boyfriend so she's
already got an army guy that she's right
on the side [__] in the time of
Instagram where did you find
she was something else man so Napoleon
writes this letter to Josephine and um
he's begging her to come to Milan and
join him for their honeymoon and he says
I have your letters of the 16th and 21st
there are many days when you don't write
what do you do then no my darling I'm
not jealous but sometimes worried come
soon I warn you if you delay you will
find me ill fatigue and your absence are
too much your letters are the joy of my
days and my days of Happiness are not
many so he's like writing her letters
every day sometimes multiple times a day
and she barely writes back like she
doesn't even write him back and he says
You must come back you understand
hopeless sorrow inconsolable misery
sadness Without End if I'm so unhappy as
to see him return alone adorable friend
he will see you he will breathe in your
temple perhaps you will even Grant him
the unique and perfect favor of kissing
your cheek and I shall be alone far far
away so he's got this idea that she's
with somebody he says but you are coming
aren't you you're going to be here
beside me in my arms on my breast on my
mouth and this is
Napoleon yes and then he ends the letter
with this he says a kiss on your heart
and one much lower down much lower wow
so so yeah he's like and he's constantly
writing her letters about
um about giving her kisses below the
belt so this is his neck so she's still
ghosting him still not replying this is
a few months later and he says since I
left you I've been constantly depressed
my happiness is to be near you
incessantly I live over in my memory of
your caresses your tears your
affectionate solicitude the charms of
the incomparable Josephine Kindle
continually of burning and glowing flame
in my heart when free from all Solitude
and harassing care shall I be able to
pass all my time with you having only to
love you and to think of the happiness
of so saying and proving it to you so
he's like describing himself self as
totally emotionally dependent on her he
doesn't think of imagine you're like out
in the battlefield you're supposed to be
focused on the enemy and you can't stop
writing simp letters to your woman back
home and she's like 32. do you know what
I mean and this is what okay this is I I
had I had a whiteboard video about this
you know it's not every 30 not dating
every 32 year old is simping but when
you're talking 10 love letters a day to
a [__] who's cheating on you and
doesn't even write you back I mean
that's that's simple like and you're
like the emperor of France you're like
the most feared man like you're the
Conqueror and stuff so um he was short
though right I mean she he was short
okay he was sure I mean that's true I'm
just kidding she's like she's like she's
like six foot six figure six inches
well
she she was supposed to be pretty for
her time but she had like really bad
teeth so there's no pictures of her with
teeth and I guess she would cover her
mouth when she talked and stuff so she
did I mean look my teeth aren't perfect
I'm not going to talk a bunch of [__]
but I guess there were some missing and
things like this so here's where stuff
gets really interesting he writes her
one more time he's starting to get kind
of frustrated at this point and he says
I write you my beloved one very often
and you write very little you are wicked
and naughty very naughty as much as you
are fickle it is Unfaithful so to
deceive a poor husband a tender lover
ought he lose all his enjoyments because
he is so far away born down with toil
fatigue and hardship without his
Josephine without the Assurance of her
love what is left of him upon the Earth
what can he do so he's like telling her
you're being a [__] and then he then he
basically says I still can't live
without you though and he says a
thousand loving kisses so he complains
he complains he's like where are you
finally his own brother comes to him
with proof of the affair because there
was all these rumors that she's cheating
and he just wouldn't hear of it he would
not believe people um finally his own
brother comes with like kids her or
something no sadly no did they I'm not
saying like they should but like okay
did these cheating women never get like
beheaded or is that not a thing or well
she could get away with this because
she's basically the you know she's like
the empress so he could have done
something about it if he wanted to he
could have divorced her he eventually
does and we'll get to why in just a
second but he just didn't like he could
have done something because this is why
people kept coming to him and being like
bro she's cheating like the reason she
doesn't write you the reason she won't
like come join you in the field to even
consecrate the marriages because he's
got another one she's getting literally
getting plowed by Chad while this dude's
off at War wait they didn't even
consecrate the marriage well they had
been screwing around before that so it's
not the biggest deal but no he went
straight from like the wedding he had to
go back to war and he wanted her to to
be there with him and she wouldn't come
she was back at home having an affair so
women finally his brother comes to him
with proof of the of the affair and oh
God this is another one right before
this that's so bad right before he finds
out for sure she's cheating he says you
know that I will never forget the little
visit you know to the little black
forest I kiss it a thousand times and
wait impatiently for the moment I will
be in it live within Josephine is to
live in the Elysian field kisses on your
mouth eyes your breath everywhere
everywhere so he's constantly talking
about like you know giving her kisses
downstairs while she's at home like
getting plowed by Chad so that's pretty
bad so finally he gets confronted with
proof of the affair he absolutely flips
out he gets super angry he finally has
to like face this and he writes her a
letter it says I don't love you anymore
on the contrary I detest you you are a
vile mean beastly [__] you don't write
me at all you don't love your husband
you know how happy you're letters make
him and you don't write him even six
lines of nonsense soon I hope I will be
holding you in my arms then I will cover
you with a million hot kisses burning
like the equator
like you're a dirty lying [__] you're a
beastly [__] but also I can't wait to be
with you again Napoleon have not what
was his mother like this is what I'm
like oh that's a really good question
and I have the same question and I found
out so and his life is super well
documented there's so much documentation
on his life I was actually able to find
out he was a mama's boy okay he was a
mama's boy and uh he spent all of his
time as the young kid like really really
close with his mother before they sent
him to like the million the military
school and he actually said there's a
written quote from him saying the future
Destiny of the child is always the work
of the mother so was the mom was the mom
like loyal to the husband is there any
like as far as I know like there's not a
ton about his parents like there's a lot
of information about them like what
their lineage was and that they were
rich and stuff like and they stayed
married but it says that he had like a
very overbearing mother like a really
strong that's what that's what because
like what I found is that when like the
Sun have a weird dynamic with women it's
because the order of the family that he
grew up in was off so again where the
what the man took orders from the wife
and then it creates Sims so a lot of
times we talk about single mother homes
but the thing they don't talk about is
two parent homes but the mother's
overbearing and I find that the sun's
from there typically are weak where they
might be like successful they might go
on to do the right thing but they're
just like weak like boys does that make
sense yeah we're like especially when it
comes to women they just tend to like
submit to women thinking that that's the
way you deal with them when yeah when
it's certainly not by the way another
side note he was engaged to a hot 18
year old Swedish Queen before he met
this Broad and broke off that engagement
to be with her
yeah do you know what I find so I find
it's really interesting looking back at
history and realizing it's like the same
people as today just in like different
like it's like a weird it's weird you
know that part like because before you
kind of look at history as this
different time but I feel like the women
like the 32 like Josephine they're like
the predatory women where they don't
they might beat out younger women with
these stupid games but they always hate
the men they work on yeah that's
basically what it was and there's like
other documentation about her life
saying that she was really skilled at
choosing men who she knew she could kind
of manipulate and who would pay her
debts because her big thing was she was
a huge spender and so he was always
paying her debt and she had huge debts
so he's taking like massive amounts of
his wealth hey for her like really
opulent lifestyle while she's cheating
while she doesn't write him while she
won't even join him
um and so he confronts her with this
affair and she just straight up denies
it even though there's proof even though
his brother knows every everybody knows
about this and she basically guilts him
and basically says like how dare you
accuse me of this I can't believe I
can't believe he would do this right so
finally he said oh yeah she so this is
her she doesn't write a letter to
Napoleon but she writes it to her um the
guy she's having an affair with his name
was hippolyte Charles uh and she's
writing him a letter about how much she
hates Napoleon's family they don't
approve they're angry because she treats
him so bad and she writes him something
saying I'm Going to the Country my dear
hippolyte only you can restore me to
happiness tell me that you love me tell
me that you love only me I do I send you
a thousand Tender Kisses and I am all
yours yes my hippolyte they all have my
hatred you alone have my tenderness my
love they must see how I abort them for
the frightful State I've been in they
see my regrets my hopelessness that
being deprived of seeing you as often as
I desire to hippolyte I'll kill myself
yes I want to end a life which from now
on can only be burdensome to me if it
cannot be consecrated to you so she's
writing her her um the guy she's
cheating with saying like they won't
even let me come see you now because the
family was the family was like look Rod
you can't be doing this like you're
gonna embarrass all of France and he's
out in the field and he has to be able
to fight the enemy and you're like
ruining everything so they tell her you
can't be running off with this guy like
whenever you want you can't do that and
she gets super mad and it's basically
like if you won't let me have an affair
I'm gonna kill myself the classic right
this is the other classic thing women do
they get caught doing something like
this and then it's I'm the victim and
I'm gonna I'm gonna self-delete if you
don't give me what I want so yeah
while she's writing this dude letters
she denies the affair to a Napoleon
guilts him about it and he just dude he
gets so depressed that he doesn't even
want to fight the wars anymore uh he
says the veil is torn it is sad when one
in the same heart is torn by such
conflicting feelings for one person I
need to be alone I'm tired of all
grandeurs all my feelings have dried up
I no longer care about my glory at 29 I
have exhausted everything so homie is 29
years old
Conquering the whole world and he's just
like wrecked by a woman and doesn't even
want Napoleon you could do better like
go get you I know go get you the next
hot 18 year old version so even to add
an extra salt to the wound these letters
he's writing her got intercepted by
Admiral Nelson who was like the British
Admiral and remember France and Britain
are at war in this and they find his
letters and publish them in the British
newspapers to embarrass him as a simp so
all of England is laughing at Napoleon
making fun of him like what a simp he is
and that his wife is cheating on him so
at this point even though she's done all
this they're still sleeping together
like whenever he does get to see her um
he's still with her he won't like leave
her and she's still having Affairs but
she doesn't seem to be able to get
pregnant but meanwhile so finally when
he finds out about the affair he starts
cheating too while he's out in the field
he's like she's not gonna come sleep
with me and she's sleeping with
everybody else I might as well have
Affairs too so he starts sleeping with
other women and he impregnates a couple
of them but he's been with her for a few
years and she hasn't gotten pregnant so
he figures out that she must be
infertile and can't give him an heir and
this is a problem because you know
people are trying to kill him all the
time he could get killed in war if he
could get assassinated and then France
has no Heir so finally he has to he has
to marry someone who can give him an
heir otherwise he said he wouldn't he
would have even stayed with his cheating
broad if if she could have given him a
baby but she couldn't so he does end up
getting a divorce from her and marries a
19 year old Austrian princess so that he
can have an heir but he doesn't even
like really care about her he's still
stuck on this broad so he still stays
with her cheats on his wife they remain
like friends and stuff he's still paying
all her bills and he just never got over
his love for her and until she finally
died and when she died he wouldn't speak
to anybody for like two weeks and all
this craziness also he did adopt her
first step kids no and her yes kids and
he um even her like second cousin for
some reason he adopted and he set them
up in like marriages where they would
become you know royalty uh his brother
married her daughter I want to say her
older adult daughter from her first
marriage so it's just like if you guys
think this is totally new that men have
been getting screwed over like this it's
pretty old we're talking around the year
1800 here that all this is going on and
yeah one of the most powerful men on
planet Earth is just getting cucked to
death even while he's out like defending
his nation in a battle I'm crazy I'm
curious before that so like 1500 1600s
1400s were aristocratic women still
sleeping around like that it kind of
depended because like there are some
examples of like kings who would have
you beheaded if they caught you doing
that kind of stuff oh but then there
were then there were others who maybe
they had like multiple they'd have a
wife but then they'd have a lot of
concubines or something so maybe in some
of those cases they didn't care too much
kind of depends it depends on the
country and the time and the place and
it depends also how religious they were
so sometimes like this is another big
thing where I think Napoleon went wrong
he was raised Catholic and then he
abandoned the faith as an adult and
became just like a deist which is like I
believe there's a God but it's an
impersonal God it's not the Christian
God it's just like the universe right
and he and ended up coming back to
Catholicism like when he was close to
death like he came back to the church
but like the pope at the time who was it
Pope Pius VII I think yeah he was trying
to talk sense into Napoleon he was like
you need to be in the church you need to
have a church wedding and you gotta stop
letting this woman get away with all
this stuff but he didn't listen and yeah
so it didn't go so well he finally came
back to Catholicism right before he died
he like repented and everything but oh
like L's in the chat for Napoleon I
can't believe it
so I was just like if Napoleon is cooked
nobody is no but that's the that's what
people it's just weird once you see it
you can't unsee it and like once you
realize it's like there's this natural
order and I always use a boss as an
example and people hate it because
they're like well it's marriage I'm like
but it's the same like you listen to a
cop you listen to your boss right and
when you have men that are saying let me
ask my wife that's a bit weird like
that's like I know so I back you up on
this all the time because I'm like why
is it empowering for a woman to go to a
job and have a boss and listen to him or
she gets pulled over and gets a traffic
ticket she might not like it but she's
probably gonna obey the cop and do what
the cop says but for so she can obey
everyone else and that's not slavery
that's not demeaning she's still a
strong independent woman when she's
obeying all the other men but not her
husband that's the one guy she can never
submit to or obey why that makes no
sense oh my gosh it's so so funny I had
I was on a plane
um I was I was oh my gosh sometimes
these people they're like Pearl do you
just have time to tweet the answer is
yes I don't do anything
yeah it is yeah you guys all have like
real jobs I just tweet this is amazing
two five kids how do you have time
for all the three oldest or adults who
don't even live at home anymore I don't
know if you know this but I'm old okay
I'm 43. I don't have tiny babies at home
but number two honest to God I'm usually
tweeting when I'm in the kitchen like
waiting to flip the bacon or waiting to
take the cookies or something like that
I'm like they're like what are you a
girl boss I'm like is tweeting the bar
yeah tweeting means I'm a boss I know
it's like I'm like I'm like why are you
on the internet if you're a woman and
I'm like do you want only the feminists
to be on here speaking Yeah I'm like um
yeah you know I didn't realize you know
I just didn't know that tweeting I'm
like look and I'm an expert tweeter but
anyways anyway so one day I just I was
on a flight to um the UK from America
Rachel I just had the time so I started
thinking of all of these phrases that I
hated that like men say with like
barfing emojis so I I wanted to make it
I wanted to make it extra like so you
know now everyone knows my thought
process when I tweet I'm just an expert
and
um and so I tweeted like happy wife
happy life and I put like a barfing
Emoji let me ask my wife a barfing emoji
and this um really triggered tradcon
Twitter and I think I have a special
place in my heart because I feel like
tradcon Twitter lied to me like the Trad
con because they didn't teach us what
was true now I don't think they meant to
they're indoctrinated just like everyone
else but there's just something about me
where I get this like icky feeling in my
stomach because I'm like I listened like
we all and you didn't tell us about any
of this terrible divorce stuff and you
never talked about obeying your husband
like this is all super important stuff
they they yeah they don't they they like
fake cover and it was exposed and it's
interesting Rachel I know you're the
real deal I'll tell you why because of
the way you react to information I can
tell more about somebody by how they
react right yeah so if I say something
that may apply to you or somebody else
or me we can listen and not get mad
because we live in reality right so if I
say hey 25 year old women are hotter
than 35 year old women
yeah you don't you don't start tweeting
your selfies at me you don't know you
don't get mad at me and I'm I'm 20 I'm
almost 27. so I'm I would say you know
18 year olds are hotter than 27 years I
could say the same thing right this
isn't I you know and we don't and in
this case right everybody got mad that I
said let me ask my wife with a barfing
emoji and I saw all of these I don't
know who these women are but all of
these women make podcasts talking about
how you need to get wisdom from your
wife and I'm like if you have looked in
history that is a terrible idea now then
they're like Pearl what are you doing
talking I'm like you don't have to
listen like right right you can you can
take it or leave it you know what I mean
but I don't think uh that I should be in
charge of the military or you know you
know if I was ever to hold political
power it would just be to get rid of
women's political power well can you not
tell from this last example okay the
whole reason Josephine was not into
Napoleon is because he was such a
hardcore simp all he would do is say how
amazing she was and how beautiful he was
and how he couldn't stop thinking about
it he put this woman on such a pedestal
and all that told her was uh you're a
simp like you can pay my bills you can
give me like power you can give me
research you can do for me but like she
just wasn't even that into him and she
was just like and when because it just
says something it tells a woman whether
she realizes it on a conscious level or
not it tells a woman like I can do
better than this guy he's not that high
value because why would he be simping
for me right like why would he be all
over me like this unless I I totally
have him wrapped around my finger and
that's a turn off to women like I wish
it wasn't that way but it's that way it
and and so when I said that it told me
that the women that got mad were the
controlling wives that's what it told me
because you would not get mad like if
Andrew made a decision and you disagreed
with it and you even if you hated it
you'd understand that's the order of the
house I gotta go with it yeah and
ultimately he's responsible so like okay
let's say he's dead wrong and he makes a
terrible decision he's the person that's
gonna have to deal with it and and fix
it or whatever now does that mean that
like if my husband makes a bad decision
it might not affect me it might affect
me but here's the magic thing and I
don't know how to explain this this is
one of these like laws of the universe
that I can't tell you why it works it
just does when you put full trust and
faith in your husband and you trust his
judgment that much that you really will
submit you're not going to give him a
bunch of [__] you're not going to argue
you're not going to protest but but but
you know if he knows that you're like
look I trust you 100 even if you get
some things wrong I'm following you no
matter what I defer to your judgment no
matter what it make the man like I don't
know if it provides a stronger
connection to God for him like I pray
for my husband every night this is
something you should do as a wife by the
way wife tip for y'all you should pray
every single day that your husband has
strength with system discernment and
courage and that the Lord protects him
that's what you're supposed to do it's
not your job to tell him what to do it's
not your job to make sure he's doing
things right or he makes the right
decisions your only job is to pray that
the Lord does that for him period so
when you do this for a man something
magical happens where they become this
best version of themselves and they they
do become this great leader and like
every good thing in the man you love is
magnified by your submission people
don't trust me when I say that they
don't believe me when I say that and all
I can say is like look but Rachel
where's your backup I'm enjoying it so
where's your backup plan in case he
leaves you high and dry and destitute
any minute now any minute now he's gonna
leave me for a younger woman Twitter
tells me every day it's coming like just
tomorrow I'm gonna wake up he's just
gonna be gone for some 18 year old who's
gonna give him hell all day long and
whatever you know what I'm gonna tell
you what's funny I'm gonna tell you it's
funny men tend to be like good people so
even if they do leave for a younger
woman I swear I swear if women more
raising hell and just terrible if they
when men do a good woman wrong they can
like admit it and I've even seen guys
like that are so happy their wives
didn't put them through the ringer and
divorce court they just happily send
them money now I'm not saying I'm not
saying count on that right but one men
are men aren't leaving for younger women
anyway that's not even like a thing but
even if it happens I'm like you guys
realize like if he leaves you for a
younger women like you're supposed to
have had like 20 years to study this man
and like to the point like a younger
woman can't compete do you know what I
mean like okay I'll give you an example
there there's a girl that came on my
show right and she was dating she's
married or not married but like
long-term relationship like 10 years to
a guy that's like a top one percent
earner and she's pretty she's pretty
overweight pretty heavy lady and the
pretty like pretty overweight and you
know getting to know her I could see how
she got him because there ain't no way a
woman younger than her could compete
there is no way because she she like her
presence and her Aura was just so like
calming to be around she would just she
was here she like cooked for the entire
staff
I I know it made me like want to be
softer want to be like like I I could
like count on one hand the number of
women like with that presence right yeah
and so I'm like yes even though like she
was overweight she's older I'm like
nobody there is nobody that could take
and so I'm like guys and then they get
mad at me when I'm like maybe if he's
left you for a younger woman like maybe
you just made his life a living hell at
home because typically the men if you
just give them food and sex they're like
ah good enough you know yeah my husband
always says um he's like okay people
think I'm going to like let's say he
doesn't even leave me let's say he just
has an affair with someone younger he's
like what do they think some younger
woman is gonna want from me what she's
gonna want from me is to destroy
everything I have and probably take it
and manipulate me there's no woman who's
gonna be my mistress knowing I'm married
to you who isn't going to be a piece of
you know what and who isn't going to
probably manipulate me blackmail me he's
like I because he gets a lot of women
kind of throwing themselves at him and
he's like I know exactly what they want
they don't want me they want to wreck
what I have they they just want to
destroy my life they want to be they're
like they see a guy like me and they're
like I can subdue him I can control it
I'll get him you know and he knows that
he's not dumb he figured this out
somewhere along the way and he was like
ah okay I see what these women are up to
they don't really want me you know so
he's like why would I do that what am I
going to give some you know thought
power for cry but my my point is like
women whenever I say you know well why
did he leave you it's never it's always
like ah Pearl's so insensitive but like
in my head I'm like you've had 20 years
or 10 years 15 whatever it is to get to
know this guy like the back of his hand
dude I mean like you have like a I
understand the Beauty and the youth but
I'm like at some point men are kind of
content like yeah they're not looking to
mess up their whole life go through a
divorce and ruin everything unless it's
absolute hell at home and what they
don't want to talk about this is what
they don't want to talk about and this
happens to um I my um producers are from
Africa right and they talk about us some
Western men go to Africa and these women
just come in and they're so feminine and
they treat these men like they've never
been treated in their life right and
then they're like they they just leave
now you could say oh that's on the man
but it's like why have these guys never
received an ounce of obedience in their
life like you know I know am I the bad
guy for pointing this out now what
people get mad when we talk in
generalities like this but we have to
talk in generalities there's always
outliers okay is there someone somewhere
who left their wife and is a total piece
of garbage sure but there's women that
do that all the time and the the point
we're always trying to make is whenever
you say oh look at this man look what he
did he's so bad everybody goes yeah he's
a piece of crap he's a scumbag what a
jerk but if you say look at this woman
she abandoned her whole family and left
for someone else the first thought
everyone has is he must have done
something to make her do it because the
woman would never and it's like where do
people get this idea that women are just
naturally so innocent and men are
naturally so natural well and even like
when the Crowder footage came out I knew
what was happening because everybody was
like oh why is he reacting like or why
would he do like there's like he's evil
for doing that but I was like what got
him to this point and I and you could
tell in the footage no one ever asked
she was she was talking no and I I've
seen it too many times because you just
do these interviews you see patterns and
it's like she
um she was accusing this guy of abuse in
his own home constantly that's what you
could that's what that's what he kept
saying like oh I'm drawing a boundary at
abuse I'm drawing about because imagine
being in your own home and telling your
wife to do anything and she's calling it
abuse 24 seconds that wouldn't drive you
nuts and then what did they do everybody
reported on it I'm still waiting on the
retractions guys I know where are they
you can't get it right every time I
understand not everyone has the inside I
do but you just ruined this man's
reputation retractions retract anybody
nobody nobody I called them out on
Twitter too because when that when that
tape came out months ago I said to
everybody because everybody was like
here to comment on this what do you have
to say about this Rachel and I said ah
the thing I have to say about it is I'm
older than you guys I've been around and
I've seen enough of these things come
out some little audio Snippets some
little video snippet comes out to make
the man look bad everybody assumes the
worst and then months or even a year or
two down the road through the court case
and the discovery and all that when all
the information comes out you find out
that it was something different than you
thought it happens all the time like
Johnny Depp remember that remember when
everybody thought Johnny Depp was this
horrible abuser and then it turns out no
Amber Heard is actually the abuser in
the relationship but everybody jumped on
him and demonized him and thought he was
this horrible person and I'm just like
how many times are you gonna fall for
this it happens so much and it was just
like so disappointing to see like the
right participate and I understand I I
wasn't really with Crowder talking about
their deal whatever but like I'm like
you don't think it's too far to take a
footage from a guy's house from his
house I'm like oh come on if I had my
worst clip if I was recorded 24 7 I
would be so embarrassed like I'm sure
you could get it too every like and then
everyone's like oh well I have nothing
and it's always people that have like
the dirtiest you know what I mean I'm
like get off your high horse you've
never screamed
you've never
thought like
and I'm like okay and if everyone saw
that you'd be embarrassed and I'm like
it's not appropriate for a wife to be
bringing out ring footage from years ago
saying that he's an abuser if he was an
abuser where why weren't you I say women
get a year you get a year maybe I might
even cut it down to six months file your
charges if you were abused go to the
police figure it out if not get over it
if not well this is the thing I I almost
never in this I'm gonna open up a whole
can of worms by saying this but this is
honest to God's truth I rarely believe
women who accuse their acts of abuse
anymore and here's why when you whenever
you get into what the abuse was first of
all I ask every single time did you go
to the police do they ever say yes no
they never do I have never once asked
when a woman's like my ex abused me for
five years I'm like did you go to the
police no but there was reasons and it's
like okay that's one big strike against
you but the other thing is when you get
into okay what was the abuse it's always
your favorite thing Pearl emotional
abuse emotional no no okay okay Rachel
when I watched I watched oh I was
triggered oh I was triggered but I
watched that one guy I don't know who
these people are I'd like to say they
could be perfectly nice outside of this
I don't know their background but when I
watch I watched like a hour and a half
podcast of this guy accusing Crowder of
emotional abuse at work I just kept
thinking that menu I hope you tell that
to a coal miner and a guy that works at
an oil rig or a guy that works like the
fisherman things on the sea about your
emotional abuse because he and I was
like checks notes changed the schedule
on you and didn't consider your time I'm
like okay let me get this straight
that's abuse then I'm abused every day
this is a man I changed this schedule
like three times did I ghost you and
abuse you like
that's what it always is it's always
like but he said something that made me
upset or he told me no to something and
it's emotional to be I I don't or he or
we have a functioning Society then they
all said oh he he exposed himself at
work this is the cute oh this was the
the claim and I was like okay do you
have any evidence no this was the I call
them the emotional men too and I'm and
so then the second thing my second
question was why would he feel
comfortable doing that and this is the
question we never like I don't I've
never gone to work I've worked with a
lot of a lot of people a lot of guys and
nobody's Just Whipped their like that's
never that's never happened to me so I'm
like no that's never happened I know and
I'm like was this like an ex-lover like
did you got like these are the questions
I have yeah I don't know so one thing
there's always there's always more to it
or yes men are capable of abusing but
like I just my most recent sub stack
piece goes over all the data on that and
men being the abusers is not accurate
like this idea that men especially
husbands and fathers are like the
greatest threat to everybody just isn't
in the data it's not there there it's
women tend to initiate the abuse women
use more Force multipliers than men
women tend to abuse power more than men
so like female prison guards are way
more abusive than male prison guards
even in like no facilities no way yeah
they're way worse especially when it
comes to like sexual abuse oh yeah
female teachers too female yeah so like
women are no less bad when they have
power in fact they're probably worse um
and I've talked about reasons why and
everything but it's just like this I
don't know how long this myth is going
to persist that women are just sitting
there innocently and all everything just
happens to them and how are you going to
tell me you're a strong independent
woman on one hand and you can make your
own choices and you you can do you can
do everything yourself and you don't
need a man but also say you're a
Perpetual victim of the patriarchy every
man you've ever dated is a narcissist
men are all abusing you and it's like
you kind of have to pick one Rachel I
feel like these people don't know what
I've gone through in the past few years
I'm like do you know what it's like
listening to these women talk about
abuse and then every time I ask any
prodding questions like one time I had a
girl say that her ex threw out the door
and it was because this [__] wouldn't
leave his house
so I was like so let me get this
straight checks notes you were
trespassing and you got thrown out yeah
there's a girl I used to work with who
came to work told me this giant sob
story about how her boyfriend attacked
her and she's like look I have a bruise
right here because he grabbed me and he
like shoved me and all this stuff and
like through the course of everybody
talking to her about it we found out
that the reason she had the bruise and
the reason he shoved her is because she
attacked him with a broken piece of
glass and he was just trying to like off
of him and I'm like and he was in jail
he was in jail
the cops came and because she had a
bruise they took him to jail and he was
like and the glass was there it was like
a baby food jar that she smashed and
then picked up a piece of glass and the
the guy was like she was gonna kill me
with broken glass like what did you want
me to do well and and the thing is like
I feel like because we don't acknowledge
female nature it's like okay I don't
even think we see reality and I've
talked to a cop I like I know a guy
who's like a cop and I asked him about
this I'm like when women like have these
stories or whatever do you think they
believe him and he's like yeah I'm not
saying like there aren't malicious women
but I'm like I just think our emotion
this is just my theory I think there's
two types I think there's like the women
that maliciously do it and the women
whose emotions are just like so strong
and they just have this Society that's
like oh and the feminists come in and
they're like oh you're emotionally
abused and I'm like [__] what the [__]
is abuse then I'm I'm gonna call my dad
because my dad yelled at me when I
totaled my car at 16. and he was did he
emotionally abuse use me should I should
I call him up and say Dad you just you
you used um emotional Force
well and let's not pretend that again
it's like women do plenty but you're not
allowed to say that and I think so like
if you're scrolling any white lady's
Instagram you see all these little memes
and these little you know all the little
inspirational sayings that you love to
post where it's like any man who doesn't
love you at your worst doesn't deserve
you at your best or like you're perfect
the way you are and the world needs to
like conform to what you want we really
do kind of like push this messaging at
younger women because we're so terrified
they'll have the dreaded low self-esteem
oh God I think it's good I love women I
love women with low self-esteem
they're way better
self steam like my so this is one reason
my dad is based and cool when we were
growing up me and my sister he would say
to us real self-esteem comes from
behaving in a way that you're proud of
wow acting in a way that is like you
know uh righteous and good and honest
that's how you get real self-esteem not
from people telling you you're pretty
when you're not or people telling you
you don't look fat in the dress when you
do he would he would tell us like all
this artificial fluffing everybody does
that's not going to give you self-esteem
that's like a Band-Aid that's never
gonna work so he would tell us like if
you want to have actual self-esteem you
need to be proud of the way that you
behave in the world and you have to know
that you are a person who can be
trustworthy and honest in those things
then you really will have true
self-esteem and you won't feel like you
need to be abused and you won't get into
these crazy codependent relationships so
thank you Dad for your wisdom because
that's not what I got from my mom but
can I buy a third story for you do you
want to hear oh maybe you've got that I
got one more one more thought and then
we'll go you know what you know what
told that like made me think of this
when I said men should only marry
virgins I would solve a lot of the
world's problems now then I had this
group of women that would just be like
well men don't even want virgins they
get like and I thought about it and I'm
like how do you know it wasn't your
personality like like maybe there's room
for improvement I mean what are you
perfect like it was the Purity that was
the problem and it just made me think
I'm like it's never me and it's all
right you know it's okay to like have
room for improvement it doesn't mean
you're a terrible person it just means
you know there's things that could be
improved I think there always is like I
can't I can't imagine having the
mentality that like this is it I've
reach Perfection no more work needs to
be done on me I've made it like if you
ever get to that point you're delusional
all right let's simp number three okay
simp number three now a lot of people
will come to me and say Rachel why don't
you mention people of a certain tribe
when you talk about the history of
feminism what about Margaret Sanger her
uh last name is you know a certain type
of surname and I'm like yes but Margaret
Sanger was Irish Catholic her um her
maiden name was a Catholic name uh it's
somewhere here in the book but she
married a poor Jewish fellow and his
name was William Sanger so she was
raised Irish Catholic in a big Irish
family she married a Jewish guy now
here's an example of some really
hardcore simping if you guys don't know
Margaret Sanger is the founder of
Planned Parenthood she helped develop
the birth control pill she's really
really horrible woman we've talked about
her before but she marries her German
Jewish architect husband William Sanger
In 1902 and then she starts getting into
politics she joins the New York
Socialist Party and starts becoming like
this feminist radical right well what
happens is she starts getting herself in
trouble because at this time there's
something called called Comstock laws
which mean that you can't distribute
pornography or anything about any
obscene materials through like the mail
and you can't publicly hand this out so
this is when we kind of had decency laws
and she was passing out birth control
stuff that was very graphic so it was
like you know um instructional
information on sexual acts and it was
like how to use diaphragms and all this
kind of stuff yeah and she so she was
like promoting this everywhere and
handing it out and sending it through
the mail and she got in big trouble so
within two years of her finding her new
circle of radical friends she becomes
estranged from her husband shocked what
do we mean by estranged she starts
cheating with all with so many people
this woman was everywhere okay she was
all up in everybody's yeah she got
around a lot but he was like very upset
about this because they had three kids
by this time already and he just wanted
his family to stay together like so many
men he was like I'll basically do
anything to keep my family together so
she gets in trouble for Distributing
illegal materials and she flees the
country she leaves and goes to England
she she had sponsors wealthy sponsors
who helped her like evade Justice and
leave so she wouldn't get prosecuted and
what what does he do while she's away in
Europe he starts passing out the same
materials and tells the police it wasn't
her it was me
let you can arrest me so he lets the
cops arrest him he takes the rap for her
he gets serious jail time for it how
long do you go to jail well a few years
at least no yeah so yeah she flees to
avoid pressure she should have divorced
her and took the kids well we should
have that's exactly what he should have
said he didn't could he could he have
like because he probably wouldn't have
got the kids oh he would have back then
oh yeah oh yeah especially because I
mean she had a reputation already and
she was wanting she was a wanted
criminal oh [__] okay right so if he
would have gone to the court and said
look I need custody of my kids and I
gotta get a divorce he totally would
have been granted one but he was in love
with her and sin so while she was away
in Europe having affairs with multiple
partners her husband good old bill is
taking care of the little kids and then
because he goes to jail he has to send
them to boarding schools because he goes
to jail on her behalf so he sends her
letters from jail begging to reconcile
professing his love for her same as
Napoleon his deep desire to reunite his
family and she responded with like a
callous letter asking him for a divorce
because yeah because she so you're in
jail doing jail time for me and now I
want a divorce because I have boyfriends
she had like and we wonder why we wonder
why some men go mad and just like kill
[__] do you know what I mean like I'm
not I don't want to [__] blame sorry I
got that I'm a swearer guys I don't know
what to tell you I'm Irish I'm Irish all
right like like I do too maybe that's
why we think the same yeah yeah
um but so it gets worse so now that he's
in jail taking the rap for her she's
like great I can come back to America so
she goes back to America for a little
bit he sends her letters begging her to
visit him in prison and she won't she
didn't she wouldn't even go see the guy
who is doing jail time for her and while
this happened did she come back and see
her kids did she come get her kids no
they never she left them where they were
and her daughter got really sick and
they had been sending her letters saying
you know your daughter's really sick her
sons are sending her letters begging her
to come home they don't like being in
this like she left him at like a weird
boarding school too it wasn't even like
a nice one it was like a really shitty
one for like abandoned kids basically
and so her sons are begging her to come
back her husband's begging her to come
back and they say hey your daughter is
sick so finally she comes to try to see
her sick daughter and the child has just
died so not only does the husband end up
divorced and doing jail time for her but
their child actually passed and her one
son always blamed her he always said
look she would leave us with anyone she
didn't care who and she'd leave us
anywhere and if she hadn't done that my
sister would never have died I'll tell
you what I'll tell you what um the truth
always women think they can get away
with this [__] the truth if you have
kids yeah or who you date the truth
comes out eventually and I can say this
because hundreds of years later we're
talking about these closed captioning
not available
[Laughter]
it's so infuriating to me it's like
women everybody's like you can't say
this you hate women the men will do
terrible things to us and I'm like but
this lady can send her husband to jail
on her behalf to take the rap she let
her daughter die alone in like a shitty
orphanage and she gets hailed as a hero
but yeah her her son did come out the
one son was kind of like mama's boy and
became like a Planned Parenthood
director himself but the other son blew
the whistle on the whole thing and was
like no she was terrible she never cared
about us she left us anywhere with
anyone so that she could go party and
she was like into she was into women and
men like this woman was wild she was
just hoeing it up out there so it's like
and this man was just like he could have
divorced her he didn't have to go to
jail and but if he wouldn't have sent
his children would have lived so you're
sacrificing your children with yourself
like that you can't do that it's again
the man is abandoning his god-given duty
to simp for a woman and so I I just feel
like the Lord does not favor that and
he's gonna not necessarily he might
leave you like the Lord might say fine
you're gonna turn your back on your
god-given duties then you're on your own
well they say we hate women it works out
so bad when they say we hate women but
we just hate stupid women yeah well when
you were talking about the nice lady
that made you feel like you wanted to be
more feminine just from being around her
I have a couple friends like that you
know what I mean that they're just like
gentle and graceful because I'm not I'm
like a bull in a china shop that's like
my I I think I'm a good wife but I'm not
like graceful I'm not like super
Irish
I'm just kind of but we're full I don't
know it's it's the the Irish this is
what I say because the Irish it's like
they're they're kind of like Bowls in
the china shop but a lot of fun do you
know what I mean yeah
and there's a very very low divorce rate
in Ireland so go us but are you really
is it really because I think I was just
looking at it yesterday because like
it's so bad in certain countries and I
was looking at the data and I was
surprised that Ireland was okay I'm
gonna tell you what I found because I've
been to Ireland I think divorce is
phasing out there no sorry not divorce
marriage oh because they don't get
married till 35. so that kind of tells
me yeah because when I you know it's
interesting yeah it's interesting I was
like it's kind of going downhill
everywhere because they'll talk about
these Eastern European women that are
the best and now that's what I was
looking at and I'm and I'm German so I'm
like I mean that's that's kind of eat
whatever but like but I'm also German
but I'm like okay let me get this
straight the Eastern European women have
like less kids and they're like the
queens of abortion I mean they look good
don't get me wrong but I'm like I was
thinking I'm like it kind of if we're
gonna go traditionalism I was like we
got to do marriage rate like the age
they get married and the number of kids
it seems like Africa is winning right
now that's what I mean yeah Africa is
the only place that has above
replacement birth rates yeah um and the
thing like my book that's coming out
next year because it's huge it's taking
forever because it's really in-depth and
it's gonna be it's not going to be a
smaller book like this one it's going to
be big and heavy and really in depth
about how the Bolshevik Revolution and
that type of feminism really destroyed
Eastern Europe and Russia and that's
where all the abortion and the like
failed marriages and all this stuff how
that got rooted in there and like how
they were it was like a whole different
strategy of how to get to the window
there then is that Portugal's divorce
rate like 70 I saw that I was like
everyone on Twitter yeah everyone
article is one of the worst yeah there's
a few that are like so bad Russia is
really bad too yeah because like I'm
Orthodox and everybody on Twitter was
like it's not like this in Orthodox
countries Romania is pretty good but
there's a lot of Eastern Bloc and
Russian women who were deeply deeply
affected by the Bolshevik brand of
feminism and how bad that was so that
book's going to get into all of that
because there's so much history and
there's so many horrific women during
that time period that screwed things up
for everybody so but like the moral of
the story here is none of these men no
matter if they were powerful or not they
met horrible ends they met a horrible
end and their life was ruined and their
legacy was tarnished because of simping
so don't simp it's a disease it is it's
a plague on Humanity oh my gosh so
Margaret's saying William Sanger is like
the last the last simp right now the
biggest Cent wow we could do a whole
series of synths though because there's
so many I think there's so many good I
think I hate simps just as much as I
hate radical feminine because I thought
about this I'm like I genuinely think
that the women believe it like I know
they do yeah yeah the men really do the
men have like logic in there somewhere
so I'm like you know better like you
have a gut like you have it in you to
not be batshit crazy now these women a
lot of them were doomed now I know I
know they're like well take
accountability I mean women are just
like we're just different do you know
what I mean like how can how can women
so like how was Josephine really
supposed to take accountability if
Napoleon's just gonna continue to tell
her how amazing she is no matter what
she does to us like the message all
these men send these women is that I'll
get a little mad at you but I'm still
gonna give you everything you want no
matter how bad you behave right so simps
really do kind of like ruin the women
because it's like if you're gonna let
her get away with all that why would she
not it's just like Nina ingdahl or some
of these like modern women that like
they can sleep with everybody on planet
Earth they can act badly they can be
promiscuous and as long as they're hot
and some Logan Paul is willing to give
them a giant Diamond like why would they
stop well and that's why I don't even
think sipping is about money because
like what'll happen this is just like
the Dynamics I see I have like three
categories right the Chads the simps and
the sexless sexless men aren't really
part of the equation okay yeah now a
Chad a Chad it doesn't people think a
Chad is it is the hottest guys right
like some Chads are still simps they get
away with it they're just ungodly hot
and Rich right yeah but what happens
with a lot of these chat is they still
go into a different social group the
women are hotter they're still going to
get a woman but it's like the Nina AG
doll Logan Paul is a good looking guy
he's rich like women would line up to
date him but for whatever reason his
mindset still puts women on the pedestal
so you could have a guy that's a
construction worker and okay he's not
gonna get like a Nina AG doll like that
how like maybe it's less hot but he
still behaves like a Chad and maybe it's
like a four or five or a six whatever
whatever hotness chick but she's still
gonna have to work to be with you yeah
and that's the way it's supposed to be
yes I think so too we I wish we were
logical like the men and appreciated
things we got for free but guys we're
women you're trying to make women into
men yeah and it's like if you if you
this is what I was telling simps on
Twitter I was like you are encouraging
the behavior you're enabling the
behavior because if you would just put
down boundaries and say no and the men
used to be able to like regulate the
simps a little bit better now the men
can't regulate the simps like they used
to as much because there's all these
like female teachers and single moms
going no bullying don't be mean you have
to be nice so like The Sims can just get
away with murder well okay I saw this
Tick Tock this week I reacted to about a
woman living in Japan for a year and she
showed her initial outfit she's like
this is what I used to wear in the gym
and she's like do not do this in Japan
they will look at you like you have
[__] written on your forehead and she
wore like the super baggy outfit and I
won't even lie I played volleyball
growing up so I'm not I'm not even
pretending like like I I because I think
she wore like leggings or something
something you know and I'm just and I
was just like yeah we respond really
quickly to social shame we respond
really really quick so if the men are
like oh no oh we'll switch up haven't
you seen how about you have you seen a
woman do a Rebrand
oh yeah oh yeah and I'm like you know
sure and I'm like all women would do a
Rebrand if the men were just like oh no
[__] I'm not touching that with the 10
foot yeah yes well you always say like a
hundred years ago they say that only
five percent of women who got weren't
virgins on their wedding night and that
even if a bunch of them are lying let's
say it was 80 Divergence or something
that's still way better than now and
it's because back then you would get
branded as the town [__] yeah and
nobody wanted that and then your your
chances of getting a good man go way
down and like just it's harder like it's
just costs you a lot of Social Capital
to to act that way and the women that
were hoarse kind of knew their place
they're like yeah yeah they were like
yeah this is my guess actually you you
know more history than me so my guess is
in history we had the wives so most of
them married The Peasants right then you
had the women that chose to be concubine
so I'd assume these are like low status
women like from poorer backgrounds
they're just like I'm gonna be a [__]
um do you know like because I I know
they've always had um not not sorry not
concubines because it concubines like a
side chick um prostitute yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I'm imagining the women that
got away with [__] Behavior are
similar to Nina Agdal still less but
similar or their High status and have
Beauty I'm guessing yeah yeah yeah and
it kind of depended on your social cast
a little bit and again the time and
place so like we're always mainly
talking about the West because sometimes
people get mad be like it's not like
that in China or something I'm like well
I'm not I can't sit here and talk about
China because I don't know like do you
know how many years it would take for me
to learn like all of Chinese history so
I kind of stick mostly to the West so in
the west yeah it's like in the
Aristocrat like Elite classes the really
beautiful women could kind of get away
with that stuff sometimes
um but it depended it depended on what
kind of man it was because like you'd
have the the napoleons who would just
like let them get away with it but there
were other people that would behead you
or like get rid of you if you did that
but uh the youngest the lower social
classes so like you could be a very
attractive girl who's like orphaned or
something right and you got to do
something so you start working at the
brothel or something or like out west
the United States out in the west was
kind of a whole separate thing because
they had a lot of brothels and there was
a lot of alcohol but it was the frontier
right so it was like if you were a woman
out there alone you were probably
working in a whorehouse like that's what
you were probably doing and that's what
they had to do to like survive that so
yeah they usually came from being
homeless yeah or not having a dad or
like they kind of had they knew they
weren't a 10. they're like yeah this is
I'm a [__] oh and they never expected
marriage or anything like if you go back
and watch the movie Gone With the Wind
uh Bell the hooker
she wouldn't she herself would not be
seen with the proper ladies she was like
oh don't let people see you talking to
me it'll be scandalous it'll be really
bad for you like she wouldn't even do
that to like a nice lady she respects
because she's like I don't want you to
be associated with me that would be
terrible for you and she didn't think of
herself as like she was like look I do
fine for my world that I'm in I'm I'm
good you know I live my life the way I
live it and you know I'm a hooker and
that's what I do but you're a nice lady
so you shouldn't be seen talking to me
late at night like that would be bad for
you yeah it was a totally different
thing and now it's like women really
think and it comes from all this don't
judge nonsense when everyone's like
don't judge you shouldn't judge people
we're especially if you're Christian you
are actually called to use judgment it
doesn't mean you get to decide who goes
to heaven or hell it just means you're
supposed to look at wrong living bad
behavior things like that and label it
as such you go no that's sinful that's
not bad you shouldn't do that that's
judgment and this whole like no judge
everything and everyone's the same
there's no right or wrong well and it's
very confusing to the Next Generation
like I think about sometimes when I'm on
shows I'll see these women that are like
exceptionally beautiful and they're an
only fans and I just think about how
like it's kind of sad their genes are
gonna die because it's like you know
like I'm like you know everyone
reproduced to make some of the most
beautiful people and I'm like now you're
you're gonna you know because I just
imagine in history we're just getting
well I don't know I I go back and forth
you'd probably know more because part of
me is like we would get hotter because
everyone picks the hot people to
reproduce with and the smartest but then
again I'm like we're kind of getting
Dumber now with the food and the yeah I
don't know so yeah the IQ is actually
going down I know Edward Dutton talks a
lot about that and he knows all the ins
and outs as to why that is I am not as
good on that sort of thing but
yeah I don't know
I don't know how getting back to the
Trad cons for just one second because
they're making me mad too I don't know
how you traditional conservatives out
there can say Pearl's anti-marriage no
she's saying look we need to save
marriage but if you want to do that
you've got to change the laws you've got
to change this family court stuff we got
to get rid of things like no fault
divorce like we have to make drastic
changes otherwise it really will go away
just people won't do it anymore well how
are you wrong I want to ask people how
is that everyone do you think things are
fine the way they are and if we took
emotion out of it where if there was a
51 chance of failure you wouldn't do it
right so just the emotion not how it
makes me feel like if you're a young guy
and you say marriage okay I'm gonna go
towards marriage like I want I want I
have a whiteboard video coming out on
this this week and if you come and say
okay 51 chance of success okay it's a 55
chance that you don't get divorced so
far first marriage but that's one that
doesn't take into account uh the men
that live in basically a prison which is
not uncommon the sexless marriage is all
that yeah or the fat wives like all this
stuff or if the man knew at 22 this is
what they're signing up for they'd say
no they wouldn't do it and it's from
interviewing average men that are
absolutely I can say like are worse off
because they chose marriage and family
there's no ifans or butts their kids
hate them they haven't seen them their
entire Community thinks they're an
abuser and yeah I'm thinking the next
generation of women are we better than
the women before nowhere worse so I
don't see it getting better until like
this should be the number one issue you
know the number one like thing needs to
be no fault divorce like that needs to
go and and actually even you know and
men should automatically get custody of
children those two unless if he's a drug
addict an alcoholic unless you can show
cause and it used to always be this way
like people were saying this to me on
Twitter yesterday they're like well but
when do you think and I'm like it didn't
used to be this way this is new you
didn't used to just be able to dissolve
a family because you felt like it or
because reasons like you had to show
cause you had to be able to prove
something and this shouldn't be a
problem now I could see how in 1800
maybe it was tough to prove your husband
is like kicking the crap out of you or
being abusive or doing something wrong
but it's 2023 everything is recorded
everything is electronic if your husband
is really doing something bad it would
be very easy and you know what guys even
I'll even be so nice I'll be so nice
I'll give you an out at 18. when the
kids are 18. now I'm not I'm not for
this you know what I mean but I'm like
if I was if I was compromising with the
luck right but because to me you made a
kid that's an 18-year commitment all
right we could say you know I I if it
was up to me if this is just Pearl's
World okay I would just give her a
divorce and just be yeah that'd be it
but you know Pearl's uh Pearl's a
compromiser I'm like I could think of
like 10 different ways that we can make
this like we can meet in the middle I
don't know the best way to do it I
understand it's 20 23. maybe I'll give
you an out for adultery I don't know
maybe I'll give like you know but it's
we gotta do something because the way it
is now this is a terrible deal for men
that that's it yes like it's it this is
a terrible system for men the way it is
now and we have to figure out a way to
lower the risk so men want to get
married yeah that's my argument yeah and
will you point out all the time too it's
like if we're supposed to be the people
that hate women how is that the case
when we're at least not lying to them
all everyone else tells these women that
you're you can get a divorce at what'd
you say the average age is like 44 Women
they get divorced and they all think
they're just gonna pick right back up
where they left off at 20 and get a
second Chad I'm just gonna get a new
husband who's better than this one and
most don't most of them don't remarry
and if they do the second marriage is
usually a much higher failure rate than
the first so you're even lying to the
women by making it seem like divorce is
the solution to any problem they have in
their marriage oh you're unhappy you
should probably get a divorce and
that'll fix it it's like no you and
usually like you said if you don't
address what you might have been doing
in that relationship you're going to
bring it into the next relationship
you're just gonna have a whole new set
of problems with the next guy so it's
not like it's actually helping women
either well and you know like I remember
being a kid and I'd like this wouldn't
even be like a relationship thing but
I'd be in a fight with my brother or my
sister or whatever and I remember like
telling my mom like this is what
happened and then I would listen to the
other side and I was like oh [__] I
didn't even think of it like like that
do you know what I mean and so it's like
a lot of times we don't even know half
the [__] that men put up with and the
men don't really complain they're pretty
you know they're they're pretty easy
going and if they got a microphone a lot
of them wouldn't have the best things to
say and so maybe like usually if there's
like you played some part into what
happened and at 44 good luck a man at 44
he's gonna go remarry he'll get he could
be 55 get a 35 year old wife yeah what
kind of guy do you think you're getting
as a 44 year old woman who's divorced
like it's not going to work out for you
but I mean the other big thing too that
I see because there's this epidemic of
like older Boomers getting divorced and
I know several people in my own life
who've gone through this there was one
situation where like the woman didn't
agree with how the man was spending
money she thought he was being frivolous
so he had to go to the hospital and have
a procedure and while he was there she
took all the money out of their joint
accounts and put it in an account with
just her name and said I'm gonna give
you an allowance because I'm doing this
for us because I know that I'm a better
budgeter and I'm gonna you know so it's
good for you I'm just looking out for
you and the guy divorced her and she
literally sat there like what did I do I
don't even know what I did and I said
listen if the role roles were reversed
if a woman went in to have surgery and
her husband took all the money and put
it in an account that she couldn't
access and gave her loans to every
person in that woman's life would say
that's abusive you need to leave him
girl right oh Devin does it to the man
everybody's like well see how it should
just budget better it's like I'll give
I'll give an exception he can get a
divorce like it's like that's why I'm
like look it I I'm okay with finding
some middle ground right I understand
because you know the question is is
there any going back I don't know I I
don't it seems like we gotta I think
it's going back right I don't think we
can really go back but can we change
things to make them far better and they
might look more similar to how things
were but it's not people always accuse
me of that they're like you just want to
be the 1950s or you just want it to be
like I mean like more like the 1850s all
right yeah but well it's just like yeah
first of all yes to that but it's like
it's not about trying to recreate the
past it's just about look looking at
things over time and going well this was
a bad decision we changed everything and
it didn't go well you know like that's
what the whole darn book is about is
let's look at a hundred years of
feminism and decide if we think it's
working out for everyone or not and the
answer is a pretty clear no so it's like
why would we double down on these
policies and on these social incentives
that are literally destroying people
it's insane and you can't just continue
to do the thing that's not working and
expect a better result that's not how
life works exactly it drives me nuts and
I just really don't understand the
everybody just loves to attack you on
this and I'm like tell me how she's
wrong I I'm not understanding all my you
know traditional Christian friends I'm
like please tell me how she's wrong I
wanted to oh my gosh I wanna I wanna
talk about before we before we wrap this
up you know I was funny Matt Walsh
freaking he tweets at me he said six
kids and married over a decade pretty
sure I understand more about marriage
and fam Family Life a lot better than
you Pearl and I thought about this
um and then he had another thing that
said let me find
it um it was something along I gotta I
tweet so much it's like I lose stuff in
my own tweets
but it was something along the line of
like single childless people shouldn't
have an opinion on marriage and I
thought about this oh single childless
people have no worthwhile insights to
offer about marriage this won't stop
them from offering them and I thought
about it I'm like so a divorce lawyer
has no insights really nobody and I was
thinking about this I'm like you don't
have to take my word I could give you
divorce lawyers men's rights activists
judge it like I could give you the
people that and some of them are married
that have the exact same opinion as me
and I'm like okay let me get this
straight but then it's like an appeal to
Authority and so like I have like the
daily wire doing the appeal to Authority
and I thought about this and I'm like
okay and the reason I tweeted this is I
didn't I didn't even I didn't think it
would get this big I'm gonna be honest I
just kind of was tweeting okay because I
noticed a difference between like
roughly under 45s and over 45s having a
very different view on Merit and it's
because the under 45s haven't
experienced or no know anyone personally
that has been absolutely wrecked by a
seemingly good woman yet yeah a woman
that was nice pleasant when she was
younger fine and then and I just looked
up their ages and I was like oh they're
all in their 30s no wonder they're so
like gung-ho get married and find a good
woman and then I started to look at the
older people that were like kind of them
like 10 20 years ago like Dennis Prager
Larry Elder you know and I looked at
them and like they're all divorced yeah
so I'm like why would you think you're
different than the people that like and
here's the thing here's the thing for
these tradcons to think about please For
the Love of All That is Holy you daily
wire gentlemen listen to what I have to
say the system we have now incentivizes
even those good women right yeah those
unicorn women it incentivizes them and
trains them over time to become worse
and worse women yes they get rewarded
for acting badly and they you really
don't get rewarded for for being being a
good wife in this Society so like my
husband's very good to me but you've
seen yourself the whole world trashes me
for being a submissive wife the whole of
society thinks I'm a loser I don't love
myself I get shamed so it's like all of
the societal incentives all of the legal
incentives and even in the church
divorce is very approved of nobody
really cares it's fine it's like if a
woman wants a divorce everyone's like oh
that's fine honey you can get a divorce
we would never dream of forcing you to
stay in a marriage where you're unhappy
and so even these people are
contributing to A system that ruins good
women that's why there's no good women
because you're reinforcing things that
turn good women into bad women so please
and the men and the men that get and
what irritates me is the men that get
wrecked the most are the average man
like this is just yeah from my because I
I do I don't even know how many men have
interviewed about this a lot I've done
so many interviews I've talked to so
many men that have been ruined by
divorce and what I've found is there's
if a man gets divorced without an abuse
claim okay because the abuse is
different the reputation destructs
that's different but it the the men that
are rich recover because they're I mean
you know
um if my like if my dad were to get
divorced he'd lose half even 70 of his
[__] he's still richer than most people
right yeah if and he can recover he and
typically those guys are really good at
making money so they can recover the men
that are ruined are the factory workers
that have worked the same job for 25
years made a pension that their wife
took all of those are the men that kill
themselves and so what I realized was
the Mary young Trope is actually you are
leading because most men are not one
percent they're not six foot tall rich
men like you guys right they're just
normal guys and the stuff like I
interviewed the men that I would not be
surprised if committed suicide so I see
what's at the other other ended this
Trope now I'm not seeing every guy is
going to do that I am not saying it's a
bad deal I'm not saying you can't find a
unicorn but what I am saying if you do
not caution the men you are being very
disingenuous because you don't know
what's at the other side of that for
them and I I've seen like it is I can't
put into words how sad it is watching a
guy who wants nothing but to be a father
to his kids like that is all he wants
and they'll say well he gets a legacy at
least no he doesn't when the kids hate
him because of years of the mother
brainwashing him yes and then he gets
them okay they figure it out at 22. well
that's a different kid right and and so
they don't they have no like they're so
out of touch and it's just like it
breaks my heart when I'm just saying
guys like you you're leading men into
destruction like they say oh Pearl's
Leading Men into destruction I don't
tell men what to do I just say be
careful that that's my advice be careful
be like
share what you say get everything they
don't hear what you actually say and
that's why the vasectomy thing I don't
say get a vasectomy but I think that's
equally as risky as marriage so David
Baker did some research and he said out
of all marriage all all divorces and he
took out he he basically wanted to make
it as Fair as possible so he took out
like maybe somewhere the woman was right
whatever and he he I can't even remember
exactly how we phrased it but out of all
divorces 15 of divorces are malicious so
that means the woman is trying to get
all your assets and and not let you see
your kids that doesn't include the men
that just are paying child support and
ungodly like it's like this is bad this
is super bad and that's why it's like
you need to change the laws to make them
more fair that's my point that has to
come first because I just don't see
evidence that the women are gonna do
anything different it'll just be another
round why would you expect the women to
do anything different when all of the
incentive is for them to be promiscuous
to take advantage to you know just leave
when they're unhappy and things like
this it's like we everything we're doing
is incentivizing wrong behavior and
disincentivizing good behavior so why do
the trade cons think that if we just
like tell people we just tell people to
find a good one and get married young
and I'm like I would love that that's I
I advocate for that but we are not there
and we have to fix things why are they
saying we don't need to fix this and I
should be on the front lines it should
be their top issue all of the Christian
men should be out there some of them are
Tim Gordon is my husband is but the rest
of them need to get on board with those
guys and follow them and demand no more
feminism in the church period end of
story get that out of there immediately
and then we have to change all of the
laws we have to get rid of no fault
divorce have show cause divorce only and
especially if there's kids there should
never be this automatic custody for the
mother there should never be you just
get a divorce because you just
irreconcilable differences or whatever
it's like there should be the
expectation that if you're going to get
married this is a permanent thing unless
something really serious happens and I
had the realization I was like okay if
you have a young son who is that more of
a risk a young son that marries his high
school sweetheart with a system that
incentivizes her to do the young wrong
thing or a son who gets a vasectomy and
waits till 40 to get married I don't I'm
not trying to like I'm not saying push
yeah we're not saying we want that we're
not saying we want it to be the case but
it is but I'm like imagine if he just
didn't talk to a woman until 40. I'm not
even saying like he does or only has
long you know I'm like okay but then
they meet to him too it's like there's
no winning like that's the problem but
yeah and I know you can't completely
eliminate risk but why on Earth are we
encouraging A system that maximizes risk
it doesn't make sense you're the only
one that understands what I say anyways
I feel validated
I was like Rachel is the only one that
hears what I'm saying like she's the
only one that I can like say something
you um Jay die like there's a couple of
you guys that I see the tweets where I'm
like okay they they hear what I'm saying
yes anyways yeah but um let the people
know where they can get your book find
you you can find my book on Amazon it's
occult feminism the secret history of
women's Liberation it's going to tell
you uh the sordid story of how we got
here uh and then you can visit my sub
stack that's r
wilson.substack.com or you can visit my
YouTube it's just Rachel Wilson well
guys yeah make sure you go follow her
subscribe seriously I'm like the
smartest woman I know
well thank you thank you I appreciate it
all right guys um like the video on your
way out um subscribe and get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt today all
right we are sending these out you guys
have asked about when they're gonna be
ships it's gonna be in the next two
weeks please be patient it's our first
time doing merch okay I don't know but
like the video subscribe I'll talk to
you next time
[Music]